I had an allergic reaction.
I think to hydroxysine because of my jaw locked in my body, and then I realized I was
numb in my private area in my body.
I also got suicidal thoughts.
An alternative medicine pediatrician said to do an EAT allergy test.
I have already went to a neurologist at an endocrinologist.
So if you've had a reaction to a medication, can you get long-standing symptoms from that?
The answer is yes, you can.
So usually a reaction to a food, you're going to get symptoms that will wait over time
if you clear that out of your body.
If you have a reaction to a medication, you could get symptoms that can last longer.
I would think that if you've got symptoms like this where it affected your whole body,
it's more likely symptoms because you have inflammation in the brain.
It's called a thermometer of lesion, where you have something going on in the brain.
If there are certain medications that can easily cross the blood barrier, and it can be
a cause of inflammatory process for it over the brain, then you're going to get these
weird symptoms that can affect one side of the body, or both sides of the body, and don't
seem to make sense.
So let me take a step back.
You get symptoms when you're evaluating symptoms.
You're evaluating where is this symptom coming from?
So if I get a symptom where it's very specific, let's say my left hand is hurtied from my
wrist down, the first thing you're going to think of is did I fall on my wrist, did I injure
my wrist when I was lifting weights, did I wrench something?
And as we get older, you can start hurting hours after you actually injured yourself because
this inflammatory process just ramps up.
But when you got symptoms that cross the midline of your body.
Or there are both sides of the body, or there are on the entire one side of your body, left
or right.
And it's not making any sense based upon an injury or a musculoskeletal issue.
You've got to think that, understand that your brain controls your whole body.
And if you smashed your left toe, where do you feel the pain?
Well you feel it in the left toe, but actually the left toe pain sensors are firing back up
to the right, crossing over and into my right side of my parietal level, my brain.
And that's what's telling my rest of the brain to move my toe.
This is happy.
It's detainiously.
So you move your toe out of the way of that danger when you just hit your toe.
So you're actually feeling the pain.
You're actually sensing the pain in your opposite parietal level.
So if I have an inflammatory process that starts in my brain, let's say, you know, I have
a reaction to a medication, in some case like this, that's cross my blood barrier, it causes
a inflammatory process in the brain.
If it's throughout my whole brain, it can affect both parietal levels, and I can get these
weird, crazy sensations throughout my body.
The problem with that is it's harder to get rid of inflammation in the brain than it
is anywhere else in the body.
So that can last a long time.
There's different medication reactions that people have had different classifications of antibiotics
that has lasted a lifetime, and it changed their whole life.
And there's actually Facebook groups of people that were exposed to these things, same thing
with other different medications, people that have had allergic reactions to them that
have lasted their whole life.
And most of the time, it's because they caused this inflammatory process in the brain, and
then damaged the brain's glial system that helps get rid of those things.
So they're called your microglial cells that helps get rid of stuff in your brain.
And when you damage those microglial cells, they're called primed microglial cells.
And that just can just be an inflammatory process in itself.
So I've referred to a video that I made on multiple holistic health hours that I'll refer
you to it too.
If you go to our website in the search bar of our website, our website is cunersclinic.com
and you start searching neurological inflammation to start typing that, you'll see a blog post
come up about neurological inflammation.
They made about a 30-minute video about neurological inflammation and microglial primed in what
to do about it from a natural perspective.
So I'm going to refer you to go to that.
Because quite honestly, I agree, you're going to go to a neurologist and endocrinologist and
all this stuff, and they're just going to go, well, I don't know, maybe you need to go
to a psychiatrist because they don't, the studies that I cite in that video are not alternative
studies.
There are studies that were done when millions of dollars were reported to brain inflammation
a few years back when the National Football League was being sued for post-concussive syndrome
issues.
So the studies are out there, the information is out there, it's just not looked at.
So I point you to some of the data that is the best data and how to deal with that.
So we need help you to make an appointment with me, but I'd start with watching that video.